que ce soit d'un point de vue
géographique ou stratégiques le tchad
occupe une place centrale sur le
continent africain
la france possède des bases militaires
et depuis l'indépendance du pays en 1960
l'armée française y est intervenu à sept
reprises un record en afrique des liens
forts illustré à nouveau ces derniers
jours lors des funérailles du défunt
président idriss déby un leader au
pouvoir pendant 30 ans et qui a toujours
coopérer activement avec les présidents
français notamment sur l'épineuse
question sécuritaire la région étant
historiquement prise pour cible par des
groupes terroristes tels que boko haram
c'est pourquoi emmanuel macron lui a
rendu un hommage appuyé au moment de ses
obsèques
cher président cheikh maréchal
cherry dos
nous voilà réunis devant votre dépouille
après trois décennies à la tête de votre
pays et tant de combats livrés avec un
discours mal reçue par les manifestants
qui s'opposent au conseil militaire de
transition présidée par le fils de
l'ancien président ses détracteurs l'ont
perçu comme un adoubement du
gouvernement français en dépit de
quelques réserves finalement exprimée
par emmanuel macron à son retour de ne
jamais n'a depuis les critiques
s'amplifie contre la position française
un sentiment qui semble prendre de
l'ampleur sur tout le continent
que ce soit au sénégal où des magasins
auchan avait notamment été pris pour
cible en mars dernier ou au mali où une
partie du peuple conteste la présence
des forces françaises antiterroriste un
ressentiment qui touche désormais une
grande partie des anciennes colonies
françaises comme le détaille cet article
de marianne
le résultat de plusieurs décennies une
politique opportuniste parfois jugée
comme néocolonialistes c'est dans ce
contexte que nicolas sarkozy a répondu à
une interview dans les colonnes du point
l'ancien président y défend son bilan y
compris en libye et remettent en cause
la pertinence de l'opération barkan au
sahel je reconnais la grande complexité
de ce sujet car j'observe que quand la
france ne fait rien elle est accusée
d'inaction et que quand elle intervient
elle est accusée d'ingérence
quant à la françafrique nicolas sarkozy
estime qu'elle est terminée mais force
est de constater que la perception d'une
partie des africains diffère de celle de
nos dirigeants français un climat déjà
perceptible en 2017 lors de la première
visite d emmanuel macron sur le
continent africain au burkina faso
fraîchement élu le président français
avait fait comme ses prédécesseurs avant
lui la promesse d'une rupture j
[Musique]
les crimes de la colonisation européenne
montagne des stars est reparti de notre
choix
je me reconnais dans les voix d'albert
londres et dans des gîtes qui ont
dénoncé des milliers de morts du chemin
de fer congo je n'oublie pas que c'est
voir alors monté des minorités en france
comme en europe
et si le devoir mémorielle sur le rwanda
ou sur la mort de thomas sankara
constitue une étape importante dont le
renouveau des relations entre la france
et l'afrique francophone
les discours se heurte bien souvent aux
actes revenir sur un passé douloureux
n'exempte pas pari de rendre des comptes
sur ses liens actuels avec des pouvoirs
parfois autoritaire un discours à deux
vitesses d' emmanuel macron qui
fonctionne bien difficilement sur un
continent éprouvée par 50 ans de
politique français sur son sol